one good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast stand happy
Friday Friday
gotta get down on Friday everybody's
looking forward to the weekend weekend
Friday Friday getting down on Friday you
have to round it out without sorry oh my
God this has been the longest [__]
week ever can you believe it's Friday
what are you gonna do I don't know I'm
gonna scream I'm gonna cry I'm gonna
strip like I'm gonna trap so this has
been the longest week ever and like
everyone that I've spoken to has said
the same yeah I feel like I know
everyone's like Mercury isn't retrograde
oh god I've been talking about Instagram
it was really fun it was like a nice um
charity event and before we started like
everybody went around and said their
name in their sign and I was like oh my
God fraudulent wait no like I was on a
date last night and the table next to me
was this group of girls and like I just
like overheard them like talking about
like their signs the whole time as a
society like the amount we talk about
signs is a it's a signal that we are
unwell yeah and like the amount of like
yeah like the amount it's one thing to
be like I'm a tourism even stubborn the
amount of like we put our like life's
decisions into ourselves we might date
certain people oh he's a Taurus I can't
yeah like what no that is not for me
um me neither so I was like I'm a Cancer
and a Jew that's what I said I like I
don't have any sort of relationship to
my sign my only relationship is that
Taurus Tauruses are notoriously stubborn
which but I feel like you know you could
like say that about anything like they
could say like Tauruses are you know
bright and we were like yeah Margo's so
bright you know we wouldn't say that
though you know what I mean like it's so
General yeah you can make it work it's
like when you read your horoscope
remember those [__] apps and you
would like to get back at magazines yeah
you would make it apply to your life
even though it had nothing to do with
they're like I do have a big financial
decision coming up this month yeah it's
called red and you pay it every month
yeah literally everyone has one I just I
can't I'm sorry couns thanks for being
here thanks so much for having me what
are you wearing today you look is that
Chanel yeah it's Chalet by toast Margo's
wearing our new toast merch that we
launched yesterday I know a bunch of you
got it but if you haven't gotten it yet
this is the Pink new crew neck we also
have another crew neck and teal that I
wore yesterday on the toast it has a
slightly different design you look
stunning Margo really truly stunning
Mark is wearing mine it's a size large
so it's very oversized I feel like you
probably could wear like a medium for a
better oversized look yeah but I love an
oversized me too you look gorgeous thank
you so much I'm so sorry this is like in
my face that's okay fix it fix it good
so I heard you say you had a date last
night I did how was it it was good
kitties are asking you're welcome
um moving on um so it's new I mean you
don't have an outlet anymore in the
snatchers or anything you want to update
the toasters on I mean you were here
last week
um do I have anything that I want to
update the toasters on I mean any good
books you've read oh things we leave
unfinished that's my next book club book
I know thank god
um I'm annoyed that you haven't read it
yet because we like can't talk about it
but it was seriously so [__] good it
was basically like do you even know what
it's about no I want to know nothing oh
so then I won't say what it's about no
but please don't but you are saying it's
like the best book you've ever read in a
really really long time like I love that
feeling it's I like have had such a book
hangover with it and it was just like so
good I just like and I normally hate
like alternating timelines but this was
just like was so well done like and
there's like twists and turns and I was
just sobbing it was just such such a
good book and there's like spice too did
you ever read love in other words yeah I
told you to read it oh you did yeah I
feel like it's a better version of every
summer after okay I actually feel like
you didn't tell me no you literally I
okay like I wanna I give you credit you
tell me a lot of good books but I
remember just like discovering it nope
no okay how did you you recommended to
tell like me on FaceTime or no like yeah
I think I either told you on FaceTime or
like you like posted a story of like
thinking about reading the book and I
was like oh my God you have to read it
it's so [__] good oh so I did find it
and I don't know I don't know oh I don't
know if that's what happened okay so
Margo said I posted it being like should
I read it and Margo said yeah so you no
but by the way you didn't Discover it
because like it's a book everyone had
been reading I'm not saying I discovered
it but like I meant discovered it on
Goodreads
like I found it on my own and it created
I didn't write it right but like it was
a trending book at the time no it wasn't
not at the time I was very late I was
very late I was very late I was late not
early I was like in our family we are so
obsessed with getting credit yes
okay but because nobody [__] using
credit because you make [__] um okay I
invented Casey Musgraves in this house
okay I'll give you that
I invented what else did I invent it
just feels good when like you discover
something and then everyone becomes
obsessed with it what's my favorite
thing to the point where it's like I
discovered Megan moroney
no you didn't oh you thought no you
[__] didn't anyone who had Tick Tock
like of course I discovered no he did it
I have proof on my Instagram like I
posted before she ever released any
single song I posted a video of her
singing hair salon she's like this is a
song that I've been working on I'm like
I waited a year for it to come out like
a year before her first song ever came
out I knew about Megan Moroni so don't
even [__] try Jackie gives me credit
for Megan moroney okay but no offense
Jackie's not on tick tock
facts okay but I still I invented Megan
Marie I've invented a lot of things and
nobody gives me oh this is the big one
I came up with Magnum no I knew you were
gonna say that no you didn't I came up
with no we didn't know I came up with
the name Magnolia you did I remember
where we were I remember where we were I
remember where we were
we were too okay because first of all
Magnolia was the second dog in the house
yes so I was the one who actually she
was a lady of the house I basically got
Magnolia like Magnolia like by a court
of law like belongs to me oh oh I was
the one communicating with the breeder I
set up all the travel and like I took
you to the airport so I did a lot maybe
I don't own okay you paid for her so I
did a lot of the work and I remember we
were thinking of names before she came
and I literally said Magnolia let me
finish [__] and then you like were
obsessed and then you were like oh and
that bread oh my God oh my God you
literally are a liar
I was obsessed with the song magnoli by
Brett Eldridge before yeah I decided
together you didn't even put the two
together
yeah yes I did yeah but I don't need
your kind of approval I know you didn't
no you didn't Emily's [__] disgusting
oh my God I know I came out we just
don't treat Liars well I'm not a liar
you're a liar actually you're a liar no
you're a liar you're a liar I'm sitting
on the blue couch when I said it
remember I remember all of it but you
didn't say it so she remembered no and
Claudia has this thing and Ben will back
up here where she literally creates
memories like we'll pretend like make up
a memory in her head and say it is fact
and just expect everyone to believe it
to be true that's not what happened it's
literally like nobody makes it up no
I'll say and I'll always with conviction
ask Olivia or Jackie because they have
really good memories I'm like am I
making this up or did we blank and
Olivia will be like you're making this
up or no that actually right because you
make things up yeah but I know when I'm
making them up and I know this is
[__] yeah it is so Megan Maroney Casey
Musgraves and Magnolia what what do you
take credit for what are like things
that you like to your core oh that's a
hard one I feel like there's a lot like
music wise I agree like I feel like um
oh also one more thing I didn't invent
but like I was the OG in this house of
Taylor Swift oh yeah that's fair I
thought you were gonna say Luke Combs no
we all came to it I think we all came to
that at the same time actually I'm Gonna
Get out no wait Margo and I have video
proof no no honestly there's just no way
Margo I have no you didn't yes the first
year Me and Jackie did CMA red carpet I
believe it was 2018.
um when it rains it pours like just came
out and we were on the carpet and I was
saying to Jackie I'm like we need to
find that red-headed guy he's so cute
and he has that's I think I I think when
it rains it pours came out like he was
already huge no he wasn't like the song
had just came out and then like I was
like
I was a fan of of his with like [__]
like Outlaw and like sharing you know
about those songs only after he's famous
no yes no and also him on Vine no I'm
just want to say like maybe I didn't
invent Luke Combs but I was definitely
the first in the family no oh hard no I
was no because it was definitely me also
because I'm I've always been obsessed
with music so I've always discovered
everyone first no but you just like to
run your mouth you know and talk about
it Spotify should do what they should
show you like when you first listened to
a song yeah like when you first
discovered they also should show you how
many times you've listened to a song
like but it's not just Spotify Raps like
yeah I just want to go see how many
times I've listened to Long live I want
to like go back to it and be like when
was the first time I heard Out of the
Woods you know like I think that would
be a cool feature free idea Spotify like
you first heard this song on September
17th not my wedding anniversary 2017.
you know yeah
okay so Casey Musgraves I would like
this conversation to end okay well I
guess we could dive into the stories
because that is what you're here to do
today and I'm feeling like you know
you're just not in like a credit giving
mood I'm not because I only give credit
where credit is due and credit is due so
that's good to know because I do my
credit on all four of those things
um so we've got a great show we've got
stories Taylor of course some book news
the book adaptation of it ends with us
and I cannot wait to talk about so I
think I think do you think you think I
think I think I think so too for the
best Side Story is that you need to know
and the past five stories that you need
to know are brought to you by State Farm
the State Farm personal price plan helps
you create a plan that gives you options
so you get an affordable price and it
comes with a lot of benefits like the
coverage you want a policy that helps
cover what's important to you and an
affordable price just for you because
after all life is just better when you
can personalize your experiences you
know like for me being so young and
personalizing playlists with you know
unknown artists like Casey Musgraves
Megan Maroney Luke Combs Brett Eldridge
Etc
um but no Jack and Ira was saying so
many things in life are so personal and
Jack you know you're like literary
carbon copies of one another with the
same life but even our personal price
plan from State Farms are so different
like Jackie's a homeowner she's two cars
I um oh nothing I owe of nothing to my
name and I'm a renter so we have
different different needs you know and
so personalization means that you have
the power to choose what you want to
include and what you want to leave out
it just feels better that way and why
shouldn't insurance work like that too
that's what State Farm personal price
plan is all about you can choose to
include options like bundling your home
and Auto policies that means you'll get
the coverage you want at an affordable
price just for you in the end you'll
have a policy that gives you exactly
what you want doesn't that make you feel
better it does like paying for like a
big bundle of things that you don't even
have just because like that's what's
offered is moronic and State Farm could
never be moronic because like a good
neighbor
okay wait let's let me do one and then
you do one you guys tell me like a good
neighbor State Farm is there that's a
great story like a good neighbor State
Farm is there okay you stunk it up too
well like a good neighbor State Pharmacy
we should have done it together call or
go to statefarm.com today to create your
State Farm personal price plan prices
vary by state option selected by
customer availability and eligibility
may vary today's episode is also brought
to you by Perfect bar oh we have a
personal anecdote I want to share if
you're looking for a protein bar that
actually tastes good well look no
further than perfect bar with their
lineup of fresh from the fridge protein
bars protein perfect bar is exactly what
you've been looking for no chalky
artificial aftertaste here I just got a
huge shipment of perfect bars to my home
and Ben walked in eating one didn't even
ask like hey Claudia is this your
special snack do you mind if I have one
he was just eating one and he was
literally he didn't even know what it
was and he was talking about how he
feels like he doesn't get enough protein
and because he can't really eat meat
that's not Kosher or whatever and he's
eating this bar and he's like I really
need to start eating more protein like
do you know any good protein bars I'm
like you're literally eating one Ben and
he didn't even know because it was so
delicious same so it's made with freshly
ground nut butter organic honey and 20
organic superfoods perfect bar has a
variety of products like protein bars
little snack size bars that are also
good and good for you you'll be sure to
find something you love Ben's favorite
which was my favorite too was a dark
chocolate was the chocolate chip cookie
dough that I had a big delivery of
yesterday and that's what he was eating
so delicious they have a rock they have
a cookie dough texture that's creamy and
full of flavor they're not raw excuse me
they're unlike any other protein bars
out there and now they come in a snack
size which is packed with up to six
grams of protein and 150 calories
they're made with only whole food
ingredients and they contain no
artificial preservatives so they are
stored in the fridge grab one after a
workout for a quick bite while you're
out just being busy and you can feel
good about what you're snacking on
perfect bar knows that it'll be Love At
First Bite so for a lemon time they're
offering you a chance to try the
refrigerated protein bars for free
here's how it works sign up for email or
texts and upload a picture of your
receipt from your local grocery store
and they'll reimburse you for the cost
of one bar it'll go directly into your
venmo or PayPal account all you have to
do is go to perfect snacks.com toast to
get a free perfect bar today that's
perfect snacks.com toast to get a free
perfect bar today all right our first
story has the book Community but also
the film community
rattled okay we've gotten a bunch of
news about the it ends with us casting
for those who don't know it ends with us
as a book that was written by Colleen
Hoover went super viral over the last
few years every celebrity Kylie and
Kendall were both reading it and now
they're making it into a movie and so
far we have gotten Blake lives I take
credit for Colleen Hoover in this family
100 because I give credit where credit
is due and I wouldn't have known about
Colleen Hoover if it wasn't for you
because you started reading before me
because I give credit where credit is I
also take credit for reading in this
family before Jackie I give you credit
for credit it's due because you were on
tour with me in 2018 and [__] you
wouldn't even talk to me because you
were reading so goddamn much and I'm
like this [__] nerd better stop
reading
yes you didn't been reading thank you
because I give credit where credit is
too no I gave you credit for Casey I
gave you credit you follow me on Megan I
did try you on Megan you fought me on
Luke absolutely we'll fight you on
Magnum and you fought me on Magnolia but
I feel like you brought other things
brought good hair
you're a [__] okay so so far the up the
cast list that we've gotten has been
like very hard we've gotten um Blake
Lively as Lily which I wasn't crazy
about me neither we also got Justin
baldoni as Ryle which I was not crazy
about either because he's producing it
like we're directing it I also don't
have like a connect people love Justin
baldoni because he was in Jane the
Virgin Raphael and I never like I don't
I don't feel connected to him I don't
like to I don't dream about him he's not
like a dreamy man for me no
um so I have like he means nothing to me
love Blake Lively and I support women of
all ages she's far too old for this role
well also I just like my favorite thing
ever and like what I feel like we've
done as a society is like with like
shows like summer activities Outer Banks
like we find these people and then we
become obsessed with them like even
Riverdale we discover new towns yeah and
so that's what I thought that this was
going to be the perfect opportunity like
I thought Sophia lacorte was gonna get
discovered and become a movie star
because she would be Lily there were so
many good ideas put out for like
burgeoning actresses who haven't had
like a major breakout who are kind of
known and it would have been an amazing
opportunity so I was let down for that
and then I also just don't see her as
Lily at all
so we actually have some positive
casting news because the 1923 breakout
star who I was literally talking about
with you last week on the toes
we were talking about 1923. we were I
haven't watched it yet I know when I
said like you have to watch it because
this guy oh yeah maybe it's so hot his
name is Brandon sklener or sclernar
excuse me and he is going to play Atlas
Corrigan in um the adaptation of it ends
with us which is already starring Blake
Lively so he has been known for his role
in Yellowstone prequel series 1923 he's
landed another major role he's joining
Blake Lively and Justin baldoni to Star
as Atlas Corrigan in the film adaptation
of Colleen Hoover's best-selling novel
it ends with us I am Overjoyed you know
what he looks like yes yes and this is a
bad picture so cute in 1923 Michelle
Randolph's um love interest in the show
um that guy was annoying yeah he is he
is I mean it's uh he's the oldest
brother so I assume it's like he's the
next line of succession
um he's the next Dutton but it hands on
Cliffhanger it's like we don't really
know but he is so hot in the film and
he's in South Africa for most of the the
show yeah so he's just like being like a
safari man with like his knife and like
his bow and arrow and like he's so hot
and he's a very good actor and he's very
classically handsome and I honestly it
never would have crossed my mind to put
him in this but I could not have thought
of someone better honestly yeah which is
just so crazy because so far every other
casting has been like really bad in my
opinion horrible so who was left to cast
now it's the young so now they're
casting young Lily yes oh and young
Atlas yeah I may be young right no there
is no yellow oh yeah just young young
Alice and for young Lily and I believe
they're doing like what we want them to
be the summer I turn pretty bad yeah
because I've seen a bunch of people like
Sophia lacour posted a tick tock she
auditioned oh she did yeah yeah Oh I
thought it was just like a pipe dream no
no she auditioned I don't know what
ended up happening but she auditioned
and then this other girl came up if you
guys don't know Sophia court is a tick
talker she has red hair she's beautiful
she's a nice girl and I would love that
for her I know and then other people
have been coming up like got my call
back like get ready with me I think
they're encouraging that oh good yeah
and what they're doing which I find
interesting is like all the people that
they are having like audition are people
who sound like Blake Lively like you
know how Sophia like can sound like but
yeah this other girl that I saw like
sounds exactly like her so it's like
they're looking for people who literally
look like a young Blake Lively are you
only seeing that for Lily are you seeing
that I'm only seeing it for Lily there
was a lot of um like a movement for the
guy who plays Conrad in the summer I
turn pretty to be the young Atlas oh
which he actually does look like
Brendan's glenar yeah so it's kind of a
good call that would be good I love him
who Conrad Conrad not the other one not
Jeremiah I hated Jeremiah in the books
and I hate him and more in the TV show
no so annoying but we did just get a
poster and uh it's coming this summer
not a release date but I'm just so
excited for the soundtrack no I can't
even though second season like if you
know the books is like stinkering I have
been chasing the happiness that I felt
last summer when I I literally remember
I was in Montreal for a wedding and I
watched the whole thing on the hotel TV
while Ben was in the other room like I
have not been
as happy as I was in that moment
watching that TV show I felt like a
little kid I felt far too old to be
watching it yeah the music was literally
tailored to me Kim Petrus Taylor Swift
yeah
um
I've been chasing that High ever since
that day well hopefully we get it back
this summer I know even if it's not like
because we know what happens in the book
we won't spoil it even though it's not
like the best like storyline I I love
cousins Beach like I love I want to go
to there I just love they really it was
a perfect adaptation I don't think a lot
of people were all bent out of shape
like there was no debutante ball in the
book like who cares it's just a means to
an end like they have to change some
stuff and the small things that they
change I don't think in the book
Jeremiah was bisexual I don't think it
really yeah I don't think it affects the
storyline I actually felt like they did
a perfect job yeah I agree but Jenny Han
does that like
to all the boys I loved before that fell
off Beyond time but that first movie was
it altered like the the world atmosphere
it altered like my brain chemistry bless
you she sneezed on it it's true
I was just trying to see if there's
another one coming
um
and then you know there was the kissing
booth too which oh no I'm just saying I
always consider those movies to be like
in the same why do we always have to
ruin things by giving it a sequel if
it's a movie no here's the thing Margo
I'm so glad you brought that up and I've
said this on the toast 100 times and I
know you don't listen so I'm sorry if
anyone's hearing this for the second
time this is what happened we all saw
the kissing booth and we were obsessed
obsessed
then we saw to all the boys I Loved
Before and we were like oh this is a
movie yeah and then we went back and
watched the kissing booth and we were
like oh
this is a low budget Community Theater
I cannot believe how much I love the
kissing booth the first time and then I
watched all it was I loved before and it
took it to another level that I went
back and watched a kissing with I'm like
how did I ever like it I never even
watched the second one I did watch the
second one it was Joey King
um playing with her ex-boyfriend who
hated her so much and she hated him
equally there was like the chemistry was
off the charts horrendous because these
two people wanted to Slit each other's
throats like it was very contentious
yeah it was just that was a whole but I
did love that time when Netflix was like
churning out young like why a yeah like
the one where Noah centenio is like
blindfolded
oh yeah like with Barb perfect date or
something that was a terrible movie
where she like literally tricked this
guy I'm so glad like as a society we've
moved on from Noah Centennial I totally
agree like I'm happy for him and
whatever he's doing but I'm just so glad
like I'm not being forced to watch him
anymore it was a flash in the pen and he
was literally everywhere and everywhere
I couldn't escape him and and by the way
I like thought he was like amazing at
the time ago after the first to
otherwise I love it before I was
literally so creepily obsessed yeah I
got the hype but they ruined it like too
much too much that's what they do yeah
um so I'm obsessed with this casting
like I feel like this casting was done
just for me I'm so happy for you that at
least we got something are you happy I'm
not feeling any like except because I
didn't watch but I'm like he's hot and
I'm just glad like that it's not like
someone basic you know we like you're
gonna trust me I trust you for sure but
I do feel like he's younger than
Blake Lively and Justin baldoni well
ryle's supposed to be older than Lily so
that's fine but Blake and Alice are
supposed to be the same age right
Brendan sklinar is
30. oh and Blake Lively's
not 30 not 30. Blake Lively is we'll go
38 35 okay that's not bad all right now
while we're at it Justin baldoni
is
Huston baldini is what I wrote they
didn't pick it up 39. okay
um so yeah
it's a little confusing yeah but I'm so
here for it thank you Colleen thank you
everybody is this her first adaptation
yeah I do believe other books of hers
have been purchased but not so many
books get bought just so that other
people don't make it you know what I
have to say yeah the only person that
should be allowed to make a book into a
movie is hello sunshine production yeah
and I think I think about this all the
time because it's so glaringly obvious
but I think that what she did was
genuinely the smartest [__] thing
ever was like she started a book club
because she loves books I mean she can
talk about this all the time started a
production company and then just like
buys the movie rights to all of these
books and then just makes amazing films
with amazing like she does an amazing
job and she probably makes so much her
company was just invested in by
BlackRock it's over a billion dollars
yeah I mean that's not surprised like I
just think like it's a no-brainer no the
whole Arc of it makes so much sense
which is why it's so successful she
loved to read and she would think like
this should be a movie and then she's
like wait I work in movies let me start
a production company and she's just a
talented like producer and actress so
she knows how to make it good yeah what
she's done um crawdads which was great
great she did little fires everywhere
which wasn't amazing I never finished it
big little lies was that her
she was in it she's in it I don't know
if she did it but there was one that I
just watched oh this is gonna kill me oh
Daisy Jones oh yeah by the way I want to
talk about that because last time I
spoke to you about Daisy Jones
um I told you that I like wasn't feeling
it by the way and also I wanted to
update everyone Jackie started it
yesterday oh and she's hating it oh yeah
and she said exactly what I said about
Daisy like she is not the right actress
so now that I finished it I'm like
obsessed with like everyone in the
camera how do we get here how did we get
out I used to give us something to see
um but I didn't read the book oh because
when it was like trending like everyone
said like that I asked was like you
would hate it so like I'm not gonna read
it so yeah I don't I can't say like
based off of what I would read if it was
good but like I just thought like I mean
the cast I'm obsessed with them like
Camila Marone like Suki Waterhouse the
two of them two of them I would take a
bullet for yeah I love them like I just
like love like all of it I thought it
was just like so well done the MU also
the music was so good which is crazy no
like most of it there wasn't a song
where I was like this is by like the
river
I know but like it's just so rare that
like music that you never hear and you
like love it yeah
so totally random side note but I think
this is a good footnote for this story I
forgot to make it a story but I'll just
add it are you seeing all this Jessica
Chastain drama she won't sign the book
okay so Jessica Chastain is currently
um in a play on Broadway that's like
really critically acclaimed apparently
she's amazing in it and every night when
you're on a Broadway show you go out the
back door and there's people waiting for
you with like you know posters to sign
and I guess last night um or two nights
ago somebody brought her a copy of the
seven husbands of Evelyn Hugo and asked
her to sign it and she said no and
there's been a lot of hoopla the seven
husbands of Evelyn Hugo is a book that
has been purchased for adaptation and
there's a huge movement for Jessica
Chastain to play Celia St James she's
this redheaded actress very old
Hollywood and really Jessica Chastain is
perfect for it on watch Robin's live she
was asked about it Andy asked and she
was like I've heard about it send me a
script like I'm down
um so this video of her saying no to
signing the book went viral and people
are like she read the script and she
hated it she doesn't want to do the book
like jumping to conclusions yeah that
she put out a statement and she was like
should I save it on her Instagram oh I
didn't see that she was like I get asked
to sign books all the time and I say no
because it feels weird to sign something
I did not write it feels like I'm taking
credit for her book by the way a hundred
percent she said it doesn't mean I saw a
script and didn't like it it just means
I'm not signing something I didn't
create or that I'm not a part of yet
yeah I didn't think there was anything I
didn't think her not signing it I
thought it was very respectful to the
author yeah and I didn't think it was
like a sign that like she hated the
script yeah no but she has to be Celia
St James and ASA Gonzalez has to be
um Evelyn Hugo or anadarmus would be
good too she would yeah I'd be happy
with either of those but anatomas gets
every role
that's so true all right ready for our
next story a little T Swift news this is
crazy have you heard about this Taylor
Swift sidestep the FTX lawsuit just by
asking a simple question okay I yeah
please explain okay you know what FTX is
it's a ticket thing no so FTX um in like
Thanksgiving time of last year it like
blew up so it was this app for crypto
kind of like coinbase you know use
Robinhood for stocks sure and FTX was
this major app that like millions and
millions of people were using to make
money sell crypto coins all that stuff
and it turns out the whole thing was
fraudulent they stole money from people
people who put money in the app like
never got it back they worked with Shaq
they worked with Tom Brady they worked
with huge celebrities to promote this
getting people on the app and I guess
they had made an offer to Taylor Swift
so when it comes to making business
decisions Taylor Swift does her due
diligence All Too Well very funny CNBC
so in 2021 the pop Superstar was
approached by the now bankrupt crypto
exchange FTX offering her a hundred
million dollar sponsorship sponsored
deal that would have involved selling
her tickets as nfts to her fans
however it never materialized before
inking the deal Swift just asked the FTX
Representatives a simple question Adam
Moskowitz who's one of the attorneys
leading the class action lawsuit on
behalf of people towards FTX they're
suing the celebrity endorsers because
they are promoted this fraudulent said I
lost money so he went on a podcast
called the scoop and said in our
Discovery Taylor Swift actually asked
them can you tell me that these are not
unregistered Securities and they were on
registered Securities thus making the
whole thing for a giant so she never
took the deal even if it weren't for
that I don't think she ever would have
done the deal because she's not going to
ask her fans to buy nfts like especially
for this tour like it was so important
and everything had to go right like
Ticketmaster didn't even go right I
don't think she would have done it
anyway but the Moskowitz lawsuit is
seeking five billion dollars in Damages
according to their website they claim
that FTX is high profile promoters
didn't properly research FTX before
participating in the offer and sale of
unregistered Securities in the form of
yield bearing accounts Swift is one of
the only few celebrities to questions
The Exchange Swift is not named in the
lawsuit
um and of course she did not return a
request for comment
so this is so crazy because like classic
Taylor Swift having her ducks in a row I
know but like isn't she tired like
sometimes you know what I mean like
having like doing your due diligence
with like everything just people I don't
think she was like let's find out if
it's unregistered she has like the
professional business people but
wouldn't everybody
Tom Brady would know better but this
reminds me a lot of fire Festival yeah
because it's like you know Bella Hadid
promoting something that put people like
in danger so true do we blame the
influencer or do we blame the brand and
it's similar to this do we blame FTX or
do we blame Shaq I don't know I don't
know I think it's like obvi you
obviously blame the brand yeah but I do
think that there's obviously a
responsibility on someone this major the
endorser but I don't think like Taylor
was really ever even if they were like
not unregistered I don't feel like they
didn't even get to the point of like her
actually considering it like I'm sure it
was like they got this deal her team did
the due diligence first and then would
bring it to her right but they didn't
they were they think that wasn't not
viable and never even brought it to her
but she comes out looking like a 100
million dollars is not enough for Taylor
yeah no for her tour like she's probably
gonna this tour is gonna gross over a
billion dollars yeah she's already
played to a million people isn't that
crazy she has like 800 000. speaking of
did you see that the video of Amanda
Stan's kids
I did I'm innocent from The Bachelorette
went to the eras tour somewhere and had
the best tickets ever and her daughters
are so cute and sweet and they were all
dressed up as like princesses they knew
every word and Taylor like saw them the
whole show and kept singing to them yeah
it was so cute there's a video on her
Instagram now that's why you have kids
yeah totally so Taylor Swift steal
Michaela oh my God just for the show I
would bring her up on stage she would be
so like Blown Away by her beauty yeah
that's totally she kidnap Caleb
I think Olivia would let and I think
Kayla would want to come I don't think
Olivia would let like concerts look
crazy Michaela's like really young it's
just so like I don't think you could
bring a two-year-old to a concert I
don't know people have done crazier [__]
yeah I see all the girl girlies like out
here pumping at eras like they are
Queens like literally going to the
bathroom and not even going to the
bathrooms I've seen have been like I got
appendicitis surgery this morning and
now I'm here yeah like no everyone is
doing the most yeah speaking of Taylor
Swift like it's actually hard for me to
talk about this story
Morgan I have like something that we
need to share
so last night what time was it at seven
well you were on your way what time was
your day it was 8 45 so it was 8 30. so
at 8 30 Margaret texts me and she says
Claudia I said yes Margo I was in my bed
you know
me time
she says
Taylor's at blank a restaurant we go to
like multiple times a week literally
every week she said I know a few people
there everyone is texting me Nicole was
there Nicole was there
taxi Margo Taylor was there having
dinner with Gigi Cara Delevingne and
Blake and Blake Lively
in the restaurant not even in a private
room like in the restaurant everyone
like the way she walked in and everybody
in New York knew about it within five
minutes like no that's what was the
craziest thing is because this happened
right before my date and then I'm on the
day and like obviously you have to put
your phone down and like the whole time
I'm just like in pain and when I picked
up my phone like I genuinely had so many
text messages about it I'm like it's
really so crazy also because notice that
there I haven't seen Paparazzi photo I
know I was going to make it a story
today like Gigi Blake and everyone goes
out with Taylor and they just had the
story two nights ago she was at Casa
chapriani right with Ryan Reynolds and
Blake Lively and so funny somebody had
texted me who was at chip Casa Cipriani
and said Taylor Swift is here with Ryan
Gosling I'm like what yeah that's right
Ryan Gosling and then the next day I saw
the story I'm like Oh my friend was just
mistaken she's obviously not obsessed
like I am with everything that goes on
in Hollywood
um so Margo and I like knew that she was
at our favorite restaurant like knew we
could just walk in there but like Margo
was on a date and I was like home
looking like a rat by the time I like
brushed my hair and like put makeup on
she would have been gone yeah and got
downtown and also everyone was telling
me like just bring my date like to the
restaurant I don't think you understand
like I couldn't have this man seeing me
like that Margo I just want to say like
you probably could have like no no I
would have been so embarrassing also
like I would just uh he knows that
you're like deeply unwell when it comes
to Taylor I mean I obviously brought it
up so like he was where oh good just so
you could talk about it yeah I had to I
had to get it out what did he say does
he like Taylor yeah he I mean he's like
no I feel like some people are like oh
she's so right now she just writes songs
about her boyfriend no no he's not one
of those
um because that's like a media red flag
immediate like goodbye deal breaker yeah
um because he obviously doesn't support
women in the Arts yeah sure okay but I
um so you didn't go we didn't go
and I don't know I also like what are
you gonna do you can't go up to her so
I'm just gonna sit and stare no I feel
like I feel like it would have like I
would have not been okay I would have
just I really like don't want to meet
her ever now because I can't handle it
I don't know like one time she sent me
merch what if like I walked in there and
like we made icon then she'd be like oh
girl with no job
no that's like crazy I know I'm totally
kidding but she did send me Merchants
even though it's probably like Trey or
you know some assistant some lowly PR
girl who was just like happy for the
task but but maybe yeah [__] dream
um maybe she listens to the toast
imagine
I feel like I would listen to a podcast
where they talk about me every day in
the most complimentary Beauty
it's like I don't want to be her fan I
want to be her friend Margo that's like
so real it's so real because you know
what's cool about Taylor it's like all
of her friends are her fans like did you
see on opening night when like Haim and
Emma Stone nail went and they were like
in merch like geeking out yeah like I
feel like she kind of likes that so
maybe like we have a chance I know I
really think she'd like to love us no
here's the thing about Taylor that I
know she would like about us like one we
respect her and we always have you don't
have a history of no we're not a
flip-flopper we're not flip-floppers two
she's so family oriented I mean hello
who's more family oriented than us no
one and I feel like when it comes to her
friendships she looks for like very few
things loyalty
Trust
fun that's us ltf ltf how loyal are we
beyond to a fault the thing is like you
can really trust me like the way I know
so much about so many things like
it's crazy and I don't say them on the
toast like I was actually thinking the
other day like I was having this crazy
conversation with like an A-list
celebrity in my Instagram and I did not
say anything on the shows because like
if I want to keep having those
conversations I can't be out here like
blowing [__] up a thousand percent even
though it kills me because if you guys
knew like you would die yeah fun I mean
no ones were fun Taylor come with us a
stagecoach you'll never want to go
anywhere without us ever this is just
our pitch like our Shark Tank elevator
pitch Taylor I know you're not in the
market because you have like amazing
five million friends and you're so busy
and they're like richer and like more
beautiful than us but what we lack in
looks and money we make up for in
Charisma and talent and personality oh
my God she would be cackling with us
joke joke joke joke joke and like we can
make jokes about like people she hates
you know like oh my God I love eggs yeah
just an idea I'm just throwing it out
there Taylor feel free to to think about
it yeah
yeah and Taylor while you think about it
I'll let everyone know that today's
episode is brought to you by single
drunk female from the executive producer
of girls we've got a brand new show on
freeform and Hulu called single drunk
female the guardian actually called
single drunk female a Next Level fleabag
so we've talked a lot about this show
again it's from the executive producer
of girls it's about Samantha Fink and
she is on her journey of sobriety and I
saw how to burn her on a podcast say
like sobriety is in right now it is and
Samantha Fink knows that getting sober
was not the end of her journey in season
one which we all watched last year
um it was a journey to get there and now
that she's sober she's starting from
Rock Bottom we'll see the real
challenges and all the hard work and
being an adult finding personal success
and learning to celebrate yourself while
sober so while Samantha thick may have
started Samantha Fink may have started
at Rock Bottom she's here now somewhere
in the middle she's 549 days sober not
that she's counting and things are
looking up so if you're interested in
like a fun good show which like there's
nothing out there these days that's just
like actually funny and light and like
has heart check out single drunk female
um the Season One reviews were amazing I
loved it again it's just nice to have
something light to watch that's like
cute and funny and everybody's like good
looking I just really like that
um it's really funny they have really
good I feel like an authentic pot Trail
portrayal of sobriety
um so free form single drunk female all
the episodes are now streaming on Hulu
enjoy it it's really good and I feel
like it's very toasty today's episode is
also brought to you by droplet if you've
been listening to our show over the last
few weeks then you've heard us talk
about our new skincare devices that
we've been using called the droplet
droplet takes powerful skincare
ingredients and turns them into
fast-moving micro Mists that painlessly
deliver them into your skin and this is
important because your skin works as a
barrier making it incredibly difficult
for your skin care ingredients to really
seep into your skin instead of just
sitting on the surface so it means like
the collagen which is notoriously too
large for absorption but it's critical
for maintaining firm hydrated youthful
skin can now actually penetrate into
your skin and keep it healthy so I've
been using the collagen in the droplet
for the last few weeks I definitely feel
a big difference in how my skin is
absorbing I feel like I used to do like
big skincare routines with like a
thousand things and then lay in bed and
it would just like wipe off on my pillow
but the droplet like it absorbs right up
we're moving I don't remember she's the
man with the channel it absorbs right up
oh yeah so the droplet collagen formula
includes other powerful house
ingredients like peptides air air dry
line and it offers the lifting effect of
injectables without needles pain or
downtime so the product is really
amazing for a limited time our listeners
can get 200 off their droplet device
that is a crazy deal at droplet.io when
you use code toast so that's
d-r-o-p-l-e-t-t-e dot i o that code is
toast to get 20 excuse me not twenty two
hundred dollars off your droplet device
droplet dot IO that code is toast all
right our next story
Twitter has removed blue check marks
from Legacy verified accounts including
Beyonce Lady Gaga Kim Kardashian the
toast Jennifer Lopez and more so Elon
musk's Purge of blue check marks from
Twitter accounts verified under the
company's previous regime has begun now
a blue check mark badge on Twitter
primarily signifies that it's the
account of a person
no it's an account belonging to someone
who is paying Twitter for the perk this
article is so shady I just rephrased it
because they were like being shady but
it's like now this is from variety now a
blue check mark on Twitter primarily
signifies that's it that it's an account
belonging to someone who is paying musk
one of the world's wealthiest
individuals for the perk just to be
clear like when you spend the five
dollars a month on not going into Elon
musk's musk's no he's trying to make
Twitter a profitable business because
they've literally been like losing
they're the biggest tech company in the
world and like has been losing it was
just like shady like whatever you feel
about it I'm like that's just not now we
lost our verified check mark and they
were like do you want to pay for Twitter
blue and I was like uh [__] no that's
literally so embarrassing I think having
a check mark now used on Twitter used to
be a sign of you know priority and and
privilege yeah and now it's humiliating
if you have one because you're paying
for it can I argue the same thing on
Instagram but you don't pay for it that
you do now not you like if you're
verified before all of this like that's
whatever but you can now buy uh where
have you been oh my God I didn't know
that I'm am I an influencer you can buy
verification now and it's like you pay
per month and but do you have the same
verification as everyone else what do
you mean like it should look a little
different it's like [__] I paid for
this it's same exact thing so now like
people how much is it
um I don't remember I want to say it's
like either 15 or like 10 or 5 between
that and you obviously have to have like
a minimum amount of followers no no
there's no prerequisites no I didn't
know that yes and it's like that's why
like I don't know if you've been seeing
more like verified people like I
actually have yeah and it's not real and
it's like it's honestly like it's
annoying no it is because maybe you have
to be a business account in order to buy
it but like that but the like the whole
point of inventing verifications was to
you know
be able to tell when somebody who's well
known know that you're looking at their
profile because there are so many fake
profiles right so really like it was
invented verification for a purpose to
verify an identity right and so this is
just weird and I feel like everyone's
talking about for like businesses
because like you
um like it makes you like look more
legitimate right which like that makes
sense but it's not just businesses who
are doing it no no it's just so weird
because it's funny because I feel like
everyone just hates Elon like everyone's
talking about this Twitter thing I
didn't even hear that you could do that
yeah this rolled out like sooner but the
difference is is that they're not
removed they're not removing yeah so if
you like if someone you know like newly
becomes verified like you know they paid
for it yeah a thousand percent well on
Twitter like
a lot of um and they're also changing
like if you're a website like CBS or
whatever you have a gold one it means
you're like a publication or a news okay
so it's it's different but if you have a
blue one and you're like a celebrity
like paying for it like that's like so
embarrassing it's like why do you care
that much no especially like on Twitter
irrelevant irrelevant I haven't seen
everyone I follow who's like famous like
doesn't have anything people are not
buying it I don't I don't think anyone's
gonna buy it but then Elon also said he
was gonna keep he's gonna pay for his
own no like LeBron James like three
people who he like really liked he's
gonna pay for them to keep it like he's
gonna buy Twitter for them I mean this
is moronic and I don't know what um but
the thing is is like
when you look at Twitter from like a
business perspective like I do believe
like
Elon is like making them like a lot of
money well I'm sure like he did lay off
a bunch of the people who like were not
necessary to him and now he's like
creating new revenue streams so like
it's weird but I do think Elon is like
actually making Twitter a profitable
business which is why he bought it for
40 billion for sure but it's right now
like long term will that I don't know I
don't know but like Elon is like the
wealthiest man on the planet for a
reason so like I trust him yeah he'll
figure it out if I had a business I
needed turning around and they were like
are you gonna have Elon do it or someone
else like I'll give it to Elon yeah for
sure
um my next story is something I'm
obsessed with that's going on this
weekend Sophia Richie's wedding oh oh my
God I was talking around the way here
stalking her on the way here because she
just joined Tick Tock to kind of like
blow up probably about her wedding her
Tick Tock handle is her soon to be
married name she's getting married
abroad so I'm sure she actually probably
is already I think they are I saw a tick
tock he was like wearing his wedding
ring so her fiance Elliot Grange and her
have hit by the way do you know that
she's the beauty director of nude sticks
yes I didn't know that that's really
smart
um she joined Tick Tock to share her
wedding festivities but like we've
already been seeing it because we follow
octopus lover do you know he's there
yeah of course speaking is that crazy
like is he friends with Elliot um I'm
pretty sure he's cousins with Elliot how
fun for him yeah
um and I've been like waiting with
baited breath to see celebrity arrivals
Cameron Diaz and her husband and son our
daughter excuse me just arrived that
makes sense why does it make sense how
do they know each other Cameron Diaz is
married to Benji Madden who is whose
brother is married to Lionel Richie out
of two I couldn't connect it this
morning I don't know who which Madden
each is married to but they're married
to Brothers Cameron is married to Benji
Benji's brother is Joel Joel is married
to Nicole Richie that is how and Nicole
Richie and Cameron Diaz are friends
obviously because of that so I saw him
being there but I didn't see like a lot
of course Lionel would be there well
it's only Friday now so I feel like
everyone's probably getting there like
today and she's being so cool about it
she's just acting like a regular girl
she's not like she's sharing everyone's
stories who's posting her but she's not
like her captions aren't like about
wedding like it's she's just so cool and
I've like love her new style of like
just being like effortlessly like cheeky
classic Timeless and a Jewish Queen I
know she converted she converted to
probably get married like under a hookah
um obsessed and I can't wait to see her
dress I feel like it's definitely gonna
be Chanel because she's Chanel girl
she's a Chanel girl right now and like
octopus lover
um who is at the wedding like is a
toaster and like it's very possible he's
like laying at the beach right now at
hotel du cup and he's listening to the
toes like giggling and being like hey
Sophia like they're talking about you
gotta listen to this pod yeah
imagine imagine yeah just like keep
turning out the content we need more we
need more I wonder if any like young
Hollywood is going to be there though
like who are her friends she's not like
a [__] annoying like a million
faces she's like she's not like a Hayley
Bieber friend I don't know she like was
for a while and she was dating Scott
because she was like with that crew a
lot but she just seems very balanced and
very normal I think so many people like
her yeah and I haven't seen like crazy
amounts of celebrities but you're right
the wedding is probably on Sunday if
it's an orthodox wedding right I'm
obsessed and he's so cute and everyone
says he looks like Ben he does and you
know his dad is like the CEO of
Universal Music Group I knew he was like
big in music yeah I thought he did it on
his own I didn't realize he was an apple
baby but you know what we'd love to see
nepo babies marrying one another yeah
100 to create Grand nipple babies yeah
yeah yeah I'm obsessed obsessed she's so
beautiful and you know what like after
Scott Disick I am deserves this she
deserves the world yeah and I'm so happy
and like what's better not that this is
why she's doing it no I know what you're
gonna say but what's better than just
like stunting on your ex with like a
better man a better every everything and
just like getting married and getting
married in like the most literally one
of the nicest hotels in the world I
don't know if the wedding is actually
there but that's where everyone's
staying I imagine it is there I imagine
it
um I'm obsessed obsessed and like
imagine just being a wedding guest a
hotel guest at like because I don't
think they took over the whole hotel no
because I see like people in the
background just like the hotel guests
yeah and if you're a hotel guest at that
hotel since it's like so private and
expensive and I think you actually have
to be approved to stay there
um you're obviously like of a certain
caliber so you're not you know obsessing
over and talking about it on a podcast
which is why we're not there right all
right I put the final story is something
I can't believe doesn't happen more an
unclaimed Powerball ticket worth 1.5
million dollars is set to expire time is
running out nobody has claimed it
so someone in California is the winner
of a 1.5 million dollar lottery prize
and they may not even know it the
California Lottery announced on Tuesday
that time is running out to claim the
prize which is set to expire next week
days have turned into weeks weeks have
turned into months and the California
Lottery is still waiting for the player
who bought a winning Powerball ticket in
Los Gatos this past October to come
forward the winning ticket which was
drawn on October 26 2022 is due to
expire on April 24th and it has these
numbers in 1936 whatever they are they
were missing the Powerball number which
is why it wasn't like a billion dollars
but they had everything but the
Powerball number so it's a 1.5 million
dollar ticket it's been traced back to a
purchase at the Mobile gas station on
Los Gatos Boulevard in Santa Clara
County the winning ticket was one of two
that matched five numbers missing only
the Powerball in the draw on Wednesday
October 26 officials wrote anyone who
may have purchased the ticket for
drawing is encouraged to search their
car junk drawer wallet in any other
place they stash their ticket to see if
they have one at this point there's no
way of knowing if this was a local
resident who bought the Powerball ticket
or if it was someone just passing
through
and you know what I'm surprised this
doesn't happen more often because
lottery tickets like are not digital in
any way like if you open your window and
it blows out the car window like you're
[__] also I have two things to say one
how do they keep track because it's like
think about it when you go to like a
bodega and you buy like a lottery thing
like I don't think that they like the
cashier is keeping track of like which
number no they're not hard so like how
do you know the machines that like the
lottery people sell to the bodegas like
track all the data that's how they know
it's like when the powerball's a billion
dollars and everyone's running out and
getting tickets they'll say I'm winning
uh thing was printed and it's in
California oh and then also like I'm J
because everyone is like so you know
selfish I'm shocked that the company
whatever it is Powerball like even
reminded like keeping my money I was
thinking that too because I was probably
thinking probably a lot of unclaimed
tickets go by with like you know a
couple hundred thousand not the billion
ones but every now and then I'm sure
somebody loses a ticket and they
wouldn't want to remind you because they
didn't want to give the money away
but they are that's why I'm shocked I'm
shocked too but I'm actually not shocked
I'm actually surprised this doesn't
happen more often yeah like that episode
of Friends like whoever it is probably
knows and probably accidentally threw it
out and it's probably like
we need to check in on them so I have
bought lottery tickets many times in my
life and I always take a picture of them
smart but I don't know if that
um is eligible like if this isn't a coat
check right like if
literally if I won the lottery and I
lost the ticket but I said I have a
picture of it would they be like sure
they think it's photoshops like they
probably maybe they could check the
barcode maybe they I could do like a run
a thing on it but like I'm I'm sure they
would need it in hand I just feel like
the lottery needs to modernize even
though if the lottery was digital
everyone would be much more skeptical of
it
is so much better that it's like it's
cash only it's on paper it's very like
you know Oregon Trail yeah so old school
so old school but better that way but
you know I many years ago when there was
like a big billion dollar Powerball I
bought tickets and I lost half of them
but someone else won and it was in
California but like I said I was in
California but I why is it always in
California that's such a good point
yeah
so those were the fast five stories
hopefully Whoever has this ticket like
get it so you can go on my lottery dream
home that's what I would do if I won the
lottery I would go but it's really it's
1.5 million so it's really like 750 000.
it's 750 000 and that's if they take the
lump sum I mean that's if they don't
take the lump sum if they do take the
lump sum it's probably like 500 still a
[__] ton of money yeah
I could use it I maybe I'll have to
check my my car in my junk drawer maybe
I have a winning ticket all of a sudden
you live in California maybe I was in
Los Gatos Santa Clara Los Gatos
um those are the past five that was a
toasty week
we're back next week that's all she
wrote That's All She Wrote and anything
else you want to say to the pubes
anything you want to promote well I want
to promote Margaret's merch
toastmarch.com new crewnecks mugs phone
cases and our new toasty designs with
our new logo our First Merch drop since
our Rebrand
just get it like I I feel like would be
insulting cheer intelligence if I
explained why they're so fabulous like
you have eyes yeah and they're so
comfortable too it's fabulous
um yeah no just follow me everywhere
Instagram Tick Tock and where would they
follow YouTube at Mark ashray wow
and yeah that's really it we're going to
Stagecoach XV oh my God we're going to
Nashville the week after I was speaking
of Stagecoach um for uh patreon episode
this month it went up yesterday I did a
vlog trying to get my outfits ready and
it was really a journey although I did
end up with two good outfits so far um I
was halfway through it when I'm watching
I'll tell you my shots later did you get
to my first good outfit
um the sweater vest yeah love love right
okay so it's like a really fun kind of
chaotic Vlog because everything on this
planet is uh backless and cropped and
some of us have big jugs and rolls on
their stomach that they don't want to
show off I know it's like kind of crazy
um so patreon.com toast for a vlog a
little giggle before you get into the
weekend but I hope everyone has a great
weekend thanks for a great week here at
the toast we're back next week we love
you dearly thank you so much for
listening to the Monday Morning Show we
deliver the fastest stories they need to
do every Monday through Friday on
YouTube so we're watching this on
YouTube please don't forget to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available podcast anywhere podcast
can be found so at Spotify
star review about a beautiful stunning
and wickedly talented we are I feel like
I'm giving about Mitzvah Parsha
have a great weekend we love you dearly
bye
great